there were a lot of visually creative
movies nominated for the visual effects
this year and we were able to work on
all of them Iron Man 3 had one moment
that really stood out for me
visual effects team on Iron Man 3 did a
great job when it came to getting the
weight and velocity of the suit right
they really mastered the laws of physics
in that movie and it's one of the
hardest things to pull off in the visual
effects world
I think Lone Ranger was the most
outstanding I really enjoyed the Train
scenes every time we received a new shot
it was just a joy to see what the
filmmakers came up with and the amount
of imagination behind this movie one of
my favorite scenes from the nominated
films this year is the opening sequence
in a Star Trek to see it from its
beginning stage to its final finished
product really gives you an appreciation
of the amount of work that goes into
these films and it was a really nice
homage to the original
this year I really loved the hobbit the
desolation of smile there's a scene
where Smaug is unveiled and he is
lumbering around and heavy and
terrifying was so well done the movement
of all of the treasure and the coins
underneath Haman is just fantastic for
me I can only imagine how much work it
was for the people working on gravity we
see a lot of visual effects heavy movies
come through the DMR room and this one
is one of the greatest ones we've ever
seen
you